AND THIS IS UNDERWAY IN CALGARY.
JOHN GAUDREAU KNOCKED OFFFF DEE
STILL LOOSE IN THE
>> JOHNNY GADREAU SHING AND A
FINDS ITS WAY PAST MARKSTROM A
POSITION. TANEV AND HERE
PUCK WASUCK
TO MONAHAN, DOWN ON
>> TKACHUK TIES IT UP ON THE
TKACHUK AND HITS TKACHUK IN THE
THE FLAMES START A CHANGE.BREAK,
THE SAVE ANOTHER BREAK AWAY
PREDS O SNEAK BACK
DOOR AND AND TAKES
THE PASS AND CUTS IN DEEP AND
IN FRONT TO THE NET AND STOPPED
BY SARAR
GAUDREAU WITH TKACHUK IN FRONT
AND
RACING BACK INTO THE PLA
[ Crowd Noise ] NOT A
LOT OF ROOM BUT THAT
LINDHOLM SURVEYS AND BACK FROM
THE
AHEAD AND OFF THE POST.
PLANKED OVER
HERE IS
GETS A
LOOKING FOR HIS SECOND OF THE
PERIODN
THE
>> FLAMES COULD GET A SHOT AND
GET A
OH, NO THAT'S NOT HIM.
LEADS THE ATTACK IN THE ZONE AND
>> MARKSTROM WILL